so i'm a mom of two wonderful girls
maybe i'm a little biased but listen
it's a job that has proven to be
one of the most difficult jobs i've ever
had but
the most rewarding and i want to keep
moms connected and supported and heard
while giving them a break when they need
it the most
so when i heard the story of the mom
behind this
viral picture and i do mean it went
everywhere i knew that i wanted to get
to know her
and this is our very first mom's time
out
i'm jana coombs i'm a mom to four
beautiful kiddos ages nine
seven five and eight months old i live
in sharpsburg georgia
my husband luke is an essential employee
he's went to work throughout the entire
pandemic
so we've been busy to say the least
i like live in the kitchen between four
kids
living in the kitchen trying to explain
to
kids what covett is was kind of hard
because
they don't understand the magnitude of
the situation
and for them to not be able to go out
and see their friends
was very challenging they didn't
understand why school wasn't starting
the most difficult time throughout this
pandemic has definitely been the first
day of ezra's kindergarten virtual
learning and
within the first 45 minutes is when all
of this took place he just bowed his
head down
and his tears were just rolling down his
face and he had his shirt pulled up and
he just was so overwhelmed and that just
broke my heart because for a child to
sit there and cry
it just shatters your world because as
moms we want to take that pain away we
want them to be excited for school we
want them to learn with enthusiasm
i was very hesitant to post this photo
on facebook but i knew that i wanted
other moms to see
and that photo quickly went viral we've
had
thousands of shares millions of comments
and it made
headline news all around the world so i
knew that was
really resonating with a lot of families
i know that i'm only one voice but i
hope by sharing my story that it
helps other mothers not feel alone that
we're just trying to keep it together
one day at a time for our kids
welcome jana for our very first
mom's time out hi
hi so excited to be here oh my gosh i am
thank you for coming on our show because
i can imagine everybody wants to talk to
you about this
and the way that you describe your
situation with ezra
you know about how you want to take the
pain away as a parent when they're
suffering i just really was in awe of
how well
you told your story and i think that's
why it resonated with so many people
how are you in ezra now we're doing good
our county allowed face-to-face learning
to start again so he was very excited
and seeing my kids happy just makes me
happy
okay so ezra is back in school right
yes okay yes he is how is that going
it's going great he is so excited to be
back with his teachers and his friends
and he just said mom it feels normal
again
so just having that normalcy happen
again just puts a smile on my face
because that's all i want for my kids
right now
and why do you think if you could guess
why this
picture made such an impact with people
i think that it's just reality for so
many like you said it's not just ezra or
myself going through this
it's all of our kids many ages it's not
just kindergarteners it's first second
third and
middle school and high school so we're
all in this together just taking it one
day at a time
i also want to mention that your husband
is an essential worker
and that's another thing that's a really
important narrative this year how do you
manage all of this together
so it leaves a little bit of less time
but he's been really supportive and
gives me lots of breaks
as well but with him being gone i think
just adding
being a teacher in to three kids and
having an infant has been
really hard sometimes it's next to
impossible
i can only imagine
you